wow it's so clean  more than just lightsaber wipes you got  a cleaning lady  bi-weekly charlotte well well well  okay madman with it you got the fresh  walls  steam curtains glade plugins  acting like i can tell you when i told  you okay i stand corrected  you found a good spot for it  thanks  can i use your bathroom before i go yeah  uh it's just down the hall on your right  hey look sorry i didn't uh  get back to you i'm just wrapping up  yeah sure  i can still try to make it tonight i'll  uh  i'll keep you posted cool  hey that was candela  yeah y'all are  mean up and she wants to talk  i'm sorry i didn't mean to no  the the lift is probably pissed stuff  yeah okay  it was it was really good seeing you  what if i wanted to stay  i don't know make sure we even  i'm not ready for the night to end yet  tonight made me happy  you make me happy  yeah me too  so so  stay  tell me baby  [Music]  there's no easy way out  you